almost all American journalism is
controlled by a few massive corporations
news voice is a one-of-a-kind mobile app
that tracks the bias and corporate
interests that infuse the news stories
we consume every day and it's completely
free to use go to news voice dot-com
slash Pakman to download it so yesterday
was Michael Bloomberg's first debate as
a Democratic presidential candidate he
finally got the polling support that he
needed in order to get into a debate now
that of course the DNC has eliminated
that individual donor requirement as a
prerequisite for getting into the
debates and Michael Bloomberg was eaten
alive I mean just absolutely annihilated
in what could be a campaign ending
debate I don't know it might not be and
we're gonna talk about that a little bit
later depends on how many people watched
the debate it depends how many people
are sort of staking their support on
Michael Bloomberg based on something
like debate performance rather than for
other reasons we'll get to that
we were wondering will it be the
centrists attacking Bloomberg because he
is more of a direct threat to them would
it be the progressives Bernie and Warren
trying to take advantage of having a
turbo billionaire on the stage to talk
about how radically different their
policies are and the answer was yes yes
to all of it yes to all of the above
everybody attacked Bloomberg centrists
in one way the progressives in another
way and I'm going to show you some of
those moments now before we do this if
you had pulled me aside yesterday five
minutes before the debate and said to me
David if you had to guess do you think
Elizabeth Warren will mention
horse-faced lesbians in the first twenty
seconds of the debate later in the
debate or not at all I probably would
have said I don't expect Elizabeth
Warren to mention horse-faced lesbians
and I would have been wrong within the
first 20 seconds at her first
opportunity to talk Elizabeth Warren
going right in on Michael Bloomberg with
alleged comments that he's made about
women take a look for another four years
and we can't stand that so why I'd like
to talk about who were running against a
billionaire who calls women fat
Broad's and horse-faced lesbians and no
I'm not talking about Donald Trump I'm
talking about Mayor Bloomberg
are not going to win just immediately
setting the tone for what was going to
be a night of slamming Michael Bloomberg
without Bloomberg defending himself
particularly well and he was taking hits
left and right it was non-stop the worst
moment for Bloomberg was when Elizabeth
Warren started pressing him about
non-disclosure agreements with former
employees related to sexual harassment
most of which we believe I mean we don't
know because their nd aide but we
believe most of it was between other
employees in other words it was at
Bloomberg's company but didn't involve
Bloomberg although eventually Bloomberg
talks about you know jokes I told that
people may not have liked and Bloomberg
was not well prepared for this really
really brewed brutal and again Elizabeth
Warren just really destroying him
senator Warren even critical there live
on this issue yes I have and I hope
you've heard what his defense was I've
been nice to some women
the mayor has to stand on his record and
what we need to know is exactly what's
lurking out there he has gotten some
number of women dozens who knows to sign
non-disclosure agreements both for
sexual harassment and for gender
discrimination in the workplace so mr.
mayor are you willing to release all of
those women from those non-disclosure
agreements so we can hear their side of
the story
we have a very few non-disclosure
agreements
how many let me finish how many is there
none of them accuse me of doing anything
other than maybe they didn't like the
joke I told and let me just put and let
me play so this is already terrible I
did nothing other than maybe somebody
didn't like a joke I told that's
terrible that's it I couldn't think of a
worse way to try to explain what
happened
typically jokes don't lead to pay offs
and non-disclosure agreements it's
already bad for Michael Bloomberg but
let's continue maybe they didn't like
the joke I told and let me just put and
let me put theirs would be agreements
between two parties that wanted to keep
it quiet and that's up to them they sign
those agreements and we'll live with it
so wait when you say a deception
I just want to be clear some is how many
and and when you and when you say they
sign them and they wanted them if they
wish now to speak out until their side
of the story about what it is they
allege that's now okay with you you're
releasing them on television tonight
senator
son of the company and somebody else in
this case the man or woman or could be
but more than that they decided when
they made an agreement that they wanted
to keep it quiet for everybody's
interest they sign the agreements and
that's what we're gonna know the
question is bound by being muzzled by
you and you could release them from that
immediately but does understand this is
not just a question of the mayor's
character so just taking shot after shot
and what we learned yesterday was that
Michael Bloomberg did not make his
billions winning any debates that's for
very sure a very good analysis of what
happened by brand-new CNN political
commentator Andrew yang about
Bloomberg's failure here is Andrew
Yang's take on it yeah you know the
field the best you know what it's like
on that stage what was the read I think
three things happened to Mike tonight
number one he just found out he'd make
the debate yesterday there were two
times when I wasn't sure if I was going
to make the debate and my team got me
together to prepare and you're really
not sure if you're preparing because
you're like I'm not sure if I'm gonna be
in this debate so Mike even though he
was I'm sure getting coached and
prepared he was like I don't know if I'm
gonna be in this debate and so I don't
think he was coached hard enough number
two he was clearly instructed to keep
his cool no matter what but that ended
up presenting as being lethargic and
uninterested for a big chunk of the
debate and the third most telling thing
is that if I'm his team you know he's
gonna get a stop in the first question
like a gender discrimination or
mistreatment question so you coach him
and you have him give you 60 75 second
answers over and over again until he can
do it in his sleep and the fact that he
did not have those answers at his
fingertips lets me know categorically he
was not properly prepared for Albie now
I could go on with the Bloomberg stuff
but it's all this bad before we move on
if you want to say what good moments did
Bloomberg have I think his best moments
were at one point there there was a
debate about whether it should be
mandatory that employees be given
20% ownership of the companies where
they work and Bloomberg said guys this
isn't going to happen and it helps Trump
that we're even talking about this and I
tend to agree with him there we want to
democratize the workplace there are
countless ways to do it work or
representation on boards tying you know
the the multiple of the CEO wage there's
all these different things we can do a
law that mandates twenty percent
ownership is turned over to employees
it's just not happening anytime soon and
making it a subject of debate pushes
people away from any Democrat I believe
and here is Michael Bloomberg making
that point so they can have some say
over what happens to their lives
proposing absolutely not I can't think
of a ways that would make it easier for
Donald Trump to get it reelected and
listening to this conversation
[Applause]
we tried that other countries tried that
was called communism and it just didn't
work that has not only support from then
at another point Michael Bloomberg also
talking about as dimensions there the
the communism thing that's a total red
herring and it doesn't make any sense to
mention that we're not talking about
communism here
Bloomberg is right that a debate about
forcing companies to give 20% of their
ownership away is a non-starter right
now the communism comment is just dumb
one other moment that was sort of okay
for Bloomberg although it ended up
falling flat was bringing up this tired
old thing about Bernie's three houses in
the country happens to be a millionaire
with three houses what'd I miss here
well you'll miss that I work in
Washington house watch the first problem
live in Burlington house - that's good
and like thousands of other for Martha's
I do I've a sub a cab to get me for that
where is your home which tax which tax
haven New York New York City thank you
very much so I don't know I mean maybe
by some standard it was okay for
Bloomberg but it was really really bad
overall the one thing that Bernie that
Bloomberg's presence did do was
energized just about everybody on the
stage even Joe Biden was fired up in the
first part of the debate Warren had
higher energy if Biden had had
yesterday's level of energy throughout
the debates he might not have tanked his
polling the way that it has the other
really weird dynamic was mayor Pete
versus Amy Klobuchar getting into some
very odd exchanges including Pete
hammering her about forgetting the
president of Mexico's name really going
hard on that and I said that I made an
error I think having a president that
maybe is humble and is able to admit
that here and there maybe wouldn't be a
bad thing to trivial actually didn't
know how many members were in the the
Knesset so yeah but you're staking your
candidacy on your Washington experience
you're on the committee that oversees
border security you're on the committee
that does trade you're literally in a
part of the committee that's overseeing
these things and we're not able to speak
to literally the first thing about the
politics of the country to ourselves are
you trying to say that I'm dumb are you
mocking me here Pete I made an error
people sometimes forget names I am the
one that has number one has the
experience based on passing over one
thing if I could respond this was a
pretty big validation he's basically
saying that I don't have the experience
to be President of the United States I
have passed over 100 bills as a lead
Democrat since being in the US Senate I
am the one not you that has won
statewide in
rational district after congressional
district and I will say when you tried
in Indiana Pete - what run what happened
to you you lost by over 20 points to
someone who later lost to my friend Joe
Donnelly
so don't tell me about experience what
unites us here is we want to win I
genuinely don't know who that was good
or bad for because it was also weird and
Pete just continuing to go after her on
this issue and I think we should put a
proven winner in charge of the ticket
this is a race for president if winning
a race for Senate in Minnesota
translated directly to becoming
president I would have grown up under
the presidency of Walter Mondale this is
different and the reason that I think we
need to talk about Washington experience
is that we should ask what that
experience has led to experiences and
certainly tenure is not always the same
thing as judgment we're going to talk
about votes in the Senate in Washington
let's talk a lot of talking over each
other there and that was another
unfortunate theme of the night
candidates and moderators constantly
talking over each other many of the
candidates being cut short in their
answers one of the moderators Chuck Todd
almost constantly with a running
soundtrack of it yeah yeah and okay okay
over the candidates answers extremely
extremely annoying Bernie had a lot of
good moments for example this one
defending workers again in the face of
Bloomberg the target for the night is
your policy thank it is my policy and
I'm very proud of that policy what we
need to do
protest level of income and wealth
inequality is make sure that those
people who are working you know a lot of
mr. Bloomberg wasn't you who made all
that money maybe your workers played
some role in that as well to share the
benefits also when we have so many
people go to work every day and they
feel not good about their jobs they feel
like cogs in a machine I want workers to
be able to sit on corporate boards as
well
so they can have some say over what
happens to their lives
another strong Bernie moment calling out
mayor Pete in sort of clearer more
direct terms this time about his
billionaire or billionaire donors Pete
visibly sweating during this moment when
you see the close-up of Pete he's
sweating badly if speaking to the needs
and the pain of a long-neglected working
class is polarizing I think he got the
wrong word what we are trying finally to
do is to give a voice to people who
after 45 years of work are not making a
nickel more than they did 45 years ago
we are giving a voice for people who are
say we are sick - died a billionaires
like mr. Bloomberg seeing huge
expansions of their wealth while a half
a million people sleep out on the street
tonight and that's all what we are
saying Pete is maybe it's a time for the
working class of this country have a
little bit of power in Washington rather
than your billionaire campaign times
your contributors look very very strong
Bernie throughout I would probably say
Bernie and Warren were the strongest
last night with Joe Biden close behind
just showing more energy than he has in
recent times Pete and Amie sort of going
after each other on weird things and
then Bloomberg really the loser of the
night so if you say to me who is the in
the net who's the biggest winner last
night I actually believe it's Donald
Trump Donald Trump net benefited the
most from last night's debate because
Bloomberg completely
self-destructed and we'll see what this
does to his campaign the other
candidates got shots in at Bloomberg but
otherwise I don't believe the needle
will be greatly moved for anybody else
because we're so far into this thing and
the only new presence on the stage was
Michael Bloomberg and overall the what
will be portrayed as in fighting by the
right even though it was making very
clear the different types of choices
that are available I think in the net
Trump comes away with a slight benefit
from last night's debates just my
opinion you can disagree with me and we
can all be reasonable respectful people
on that issue did a poll on my Twitter
about 4,000 of you voted the question
was how does tonight's debate affect
Bloomberg's polling a plurality nearly
40% said Bloomberg loses eight or more
points as a result of last night's
performance I don't think it's actually
that bad but I do think Bloomberg loses
a bit maybe has to spend another hundred
million to gain it back
I did not expect Bloomberg to get as
annihilated as he did last night and one
other thought that I had about last
night's debate last night's debate was
by far the most entertaining debate of
the primary but we also probably heard
the least about policy from the
candidates detailed policy it was a lot
of attacks on Bloomberg Pete and Amy
arguing about experience and how bad it
is not to know the name of the President
of Mexico you had a lot of talking point
attacks that's probably in some way
emblematic of our politics and media
today sadly the most entertaining to
watch debate whose ratings may have been
very very good had the least substantive
policy discussion of any recent debate I
can remember certainly ideological
differences and draw lines in the sand
were drawn but maybe in some way this is
part of the problem that we're having in
the discourse in the United States
I guess the major thing we learned of
new information is Michael Bloomberg is
not a good debater let me know your
thoughts let me know what you expect to
be the implications and repercussions to
last night's debate I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman we'll take a quick break and be
back with much more